I'm at my mother's funeral this guy
comes out to me he goes he goes hey he
goes I dated your mother back in the day
I was like if my mother was like hot
back in the day who said this to you
this guy my mother's funeral [__]
long we right in front of the ear we're
right we're right in front of the ear we
got her cream she's in the ear I go oh
he goes yeah you know my Jimmy I'm not
gonna say his last name he goes I'm
Jimmy and he goes you know my son James
I go yeah how's he do and he goes not
good immediately he goes not good I go
okay like find a leave it at that he
goes yeah he goes he's got drug problems
and he's got mental problems so he's in
the hospital right now and he's standing
there with his wife he goes he's in a
hospital right now but he goes uh he
sends his regards he goes like this no
no swear to God he goes but he knows you
he goes he knows you and he like watches
your stuff and he goes he's in the
hospital right now and he's trying and
that's our attitude if he tries we'll
try and then he looked at me he goes
like this he goes you own something in
the Hamptons I
heard